hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
beginner breakdown episode my name is
alex i'm excited to be sharing this with
you
and
uh unfortunately i had this lesson
planned for valentine's day
but we were offline for a little bit so
love is in the air here tonight and i
hope you're ready
tonight's lesson is called how to find
the perfect mate
so
i love nothing more than a beautiful
checkmate and i'm going to be sharing my
best tips on how to find the perfect
mate so whether you're looking for a
roommate a soulmate or a checkmate i do
hope you'll stick around
now to start out
this focus the focus of this lesson
will be on finding checkmating ideas
from opening to middle game positions
and so to start i wanted to share a
really short and sweet chess classic one
of my favorite games from the early
1900s uh this game actually took place
in vienna between richard reddy and
tartakower and reddy has the white
pieces he started the game with e4
and we have c6 of zakaro khan we'll be
getting back into the karaoke a little
bit later in the lesson um
d5
striking in the center
and instead of taking white plays knight
to c3 this is the classical variation of
the carl khan
pawn takes pawn knight takes pawn
uh knight to f6 this is still today 100
years later a popular variation
uh challenging the center
challenging white strong knight on e4
although it does allow black to um
possibly double their pawns so that is
an option and normally that would be the
move knight takes f6
but um
in fact
queen to d3 was played in the game
and this looks like a bit of an odd move
right instead of you know just doubling
the pawns which looks more obvious
now had white captured with the pawns i
want to put a quick question to the
audience here uh either in the chat or
live
which way which of these pawns should
black recapture the knight with what do
you think
so black to move and obviously recapture
should we take with the e pawn of the g
pawn
uh g here yeah how come
um
i kind of feel that
the being in green would be like extreme
somehow
see that is a good point um they are a
little more exposed
actually i would prefer this one though
because i don't mind the king being
exposed it's going to be pretty quick to
get this bishop blocking if we need to
in castles and i actually like the queen
having some more options um it's going
to let her use her abilities
the main drawback here is um we've lost
a center pawn
versus so in this variation
where the g pawn captures we retain this
nice center pawn and actually have the
option to push it to e5 the bishop can
come out so it's kind of like a give and
take both are okay um but i do prefer
this one because i think the bishop more
naturally wants to come over here maybe
attack the king
but regardless uh in our game we
actually instead of having knight takes
knight we have queen to d3 and again it
looks a bit odd but it does set a trap
so black in this position played
uh move um the the equalizing move here
is just knight takes e4
um and maybe we might see something like
queen takes knight to d7 knight f3
knight f6 and
attacking the queen and black's in a
fine position white's doing okay as well
but it's about equal
but actually queen d3 it looks odd but
the trappit set actually was fallen into
by target cower who played the really
natural looking move e5
this move really looks great we're
challenging the center
we have opened up the line for our
bishop and we're going to get ready to
castle so again it looks great but
unfortunately it loses time in a very
wide open position and falls behind the
development
this is a very important idea early on
black
still really wants to develop their
pieces and moving this pawn is not quite
helping them with that so that's why the
idea of taking the knights and then
rerouting our other knight to f6 to
challenge the queen is a little stronger
so the problem here is after pawn takes
pawn
we have the option of a queen trade but
that's really only going to help
if queen trade
on d3 then bishop takes
and again white's just way ahead in
development we've got to move the knot
in f6 so probably we'll trade it
and something like knight to d7
attacking the pawn we can just play f4
and white has a really strong space
advantage just great control of the
center
so this is not really ideal
for our friend
uh black
so queen to a5 check was played in the
game looking to win the pawn back
with this fork
bishop to d2 naturally queen takes c5
pinning the knight and now there's uh a
bit of an issue
so we have this nasty pin on this knight
and it's attacked
uh twice right the queen and the knight
both attack it
so what should um
white consider playing here to you know
stay safe
how do you think we can survive this
uh so like f3 maybe
definitely a consideration other
suggestions here
any other ideas or is that through the
only move
okay well f3 is definitely an option i
think it has a little bit of a drawback
because after f3
if knight takes pawn
queen takes if you do pawn takes then
the queen's coming in to the side
attacking the rook and our pieces are
just kind of falling apart it's a little
too dangerous so queen takes and now
this isn't an option because the queen
is pinned to the king
uh but here queen takes oh sorry
yeah queen takes f takes and after like
bishop c5 again black is doing just fine
here
white has a pawn in the center but it's
not really that dominant black has a
really nice developed bishop they're
about to castle
and their pieces are just going to come
to really natural squares
so black's in no difficulty here you had
a suggestion levels her thought
where
sorry oh well knight f3 so our queen our
knight isn't uh defended twice so if
knight f3 then they'll just take
and they're gonna win our uh piece
so we have to do something about it so
f3 is like the only really sensible move
to actually defend the knight but white
actually plays a really good move that's
uh sort of defending but it doesn't look
like it white queen side castles
and now
there's the threat of okay you can win
my peace
but i'm going to pin you to the king
right so this is now a counter threat um
so obviously yeah queen takes is now
losing to rook to e1
but this isn't what was played in the
game uh our opponent played knight takes
e4
and the idea probably that they were
expecting is we're coming to e1
and
i'm probably gonna have to give the
knight back after f3
but
at least black is staying strong in the
center white actually had a different
idea here
so take a second with this position and
see if anyone has any ideas
uh so work to e1 obviously the natural
move but white played something a little
stronger anyone have any ideas
uh queen e4 okay interesting idea
and what's your plan after queen takes
just rookie one
yeah so i think this is interesting but
the problem is
after queen takes and bishop takes if we
look at the material
i do believe we're about
equal bishop pair and a knight
except one big problem
black has an extra rook over here
and that's because um
if we take a look so after knight takes
we get the knight back so everything's
equal we lose a queen they get a rook so
we have to give up a rook to get the
queen back
that's not quite it it's a little more
spectacular and this is a hard one to
see so unless anyone has a guess
okay
the move played in this game
astonishingly
czech queen to d8
and it looks insane but there's a big
problem
we have a beautiful discovery waiting to
happen
and after bishop to b5 discovered check
double check so the king has to move
right you can't block the bishop because
the rook takes you can't block the rook
because the bishop takes
so the king has to move either to e8 or
to c7 let's say king goes to e8 what's
the response here
with what
yeah rook to d8 and this is the opera
mate this is the same pattern used in
morphe's opera house game
what if um instead we have king to c7
bishop d8
and everything is cut off and this is
checkmate as well really beautiful game
um
this is called the sucker punch game um
because this is quite a sucker punch
right out of nowhere this is move
uh move nine
right
just
absolutely out of the blue but this is
what i'm talking about tonight is we're
going to be looking at checkmating ideas
that come from the opening in the middle
game that you might not expect but if
you're familiar with the patterns and
what can lead it kind of recognizing
that
yeah okay this is obviously a queen
sacrifice but
with the rook and bishop lined up and
the king's just lack of area to move the
lack of mobility we're actually going to
be able to win this game
so to kind of demonstrate this i'm going
to pop up one of my own games here
so this i played in 2014 i was a senior
in high school
so a long time ago
but this was part of a tournament and i
actually missed a really good
opportunity so in the game i had the
white pieces game started e4 c5
so we have a sicilian defense knight to
c3 knight to c6
bishop to c4 a little unorthodox um
e5 even more unorthodox
this move maybe str looks good because
it's cutting off my control of d4 or
yeah d4 but now
this d-pawn is a little bit backwards um
it's not going to have one of its pawns
here supporting it and it's going to be
harder to use so normally i wouldn't
recommend this type of thing though
there are circumstances where it's okay
i just continued with normal development
knight to c3 d6
d3
my opponent played h6
probably preventing maybe bishop to g5
after knight to f6
i castled and bishop to g4 was played
bishop to e3 just developing my last
minor piece
and knight to d4
and this is the position we had in the
game uh and
in the game uh i played
a okay move i think it left me about
equal um i play well i'll give you a
chance to see see if anyone can find the
best move in this position for white
because i missed it i'll show you what i
played in a minute but does anyone have
any ideas for how white should continue
from here
whether you think it's exactly right or
not just any ideas to make progress in
this position
yeah
no please
welcome what the
the
no that's okay
so we have our bishop here on c4 you
move it
up into the left
to the left side here so you want to go
to uh b5
yeah so this is an interesting idea um
we are calling check
and forcing black to respond
probably they would end up taking our
piece with the knight and then we would
recapture so maybe something like this
happens
and this looks interesting we've traded
away our light squared bishop for a
night
and that looks
okay i think the knight's probably a
little better in this position because
the pawns are fairly closed meaning our
bishops are going to be restricted they
can't move past him and the knights can
just jump around to whatever squares are
convenient
um there is actually a stronger move
the move i played in the game and there
are some people in the chat who already
have the idea but the move i played in
the game was bishop takes d4
and after pawn takes
uh i then i played check because i
didn't want to give up my bishop
the bishop came back to block i took
queen takes and then knight to d5 and my
argument was i like my knight on this
square it's making a nice a lot of
control
but it's not quite so good as i thought
because after like uh knight to e7
i do either have to move it or i'm
doubling my pawns
so black is doing okay here
the move i missed and some people in the
chat have already seen it is the
remarkable
knight
takes
e5
knight takes e5 so
it's it's pretty crazy yeah so um
legal's trap or legales mate and the
problem here is this looks like
a idiotic move right it looks like i've
just hung my queen
bishop takes d1 but now the problem i
think some of you know it uh someone in
the chat
nyc613 already said it yeah bishop takes
d1 and now there's a problem uh you
wanted bishop to b5 which is interesting
that's not what i was expecting the
problem with bishop to b5
if king e7 knight d5 this does work
but bishop b5 can be met with knight
takes
so actually the way to force mate this
bishop takes f7
knight's defending and there's nothing
else he can do the king has to go to e7
and on knight to d5 and this is
checkmate uh the knights
whoops and the bishops just control
everything um the king is completely
trapped and it's just really beautiful
can you uh show the
bishop taking the pot again
yeah so sorry about that so knight takes
e5 yeah um
someone said knight takes d4 but yeah
the stl chess club said uh
there knight takes d4 i don't think has
the same impact because this knight
isn't actually hitting the f7 square
so after something like this i'm not
sure how white continues
uh bishop here and
let's see
king e7 oh i see what you're saying okay
okay so this is also going to be made
but i wonder if
black has a free course maybe in just
bishop to d7 i guess you've lost this
knight so maybe if we take here
queen takes
i'm taking something else it is
interesting that's worth looking at but
the idea in the game is actually uh
yeah knight takes e5 this is the most
forcing way
um
and after yeah bishop takes d1 we have
our bishop and our knight both aimed
here at f7 so this is a really key
square and it's something we're going to
want to keep our eyes on as we go
so yeah this is called the gals bait or
the legal trap
and actually
the most common way it arises
is just from this position so similarly
this is the quickest way to get there
again there's lots of ways you might see
it
um
knight to c3
bishop g4 h3 so it doesn't work right
away there is a bit of a problem if we
try it earlier but after bishop h5 it
does work
um now we can play knight takes e5 if we
try it yeah i was going to say if we try
it right now
knight takes e5 i don't believe this
works
because of
after knight takes here it's defending
the bishop
so normally the idea would be um i'll
just show the regular position
after bishop h5 and knight takes c5
black isn't forced to take the queen
right taking the queen leads to
checkmate
and it's the same one we saw before
but you don't have to take the queen
you can actually either take the knight
with the pawn or with the knight
if you take with the pawn
then we're winning the bishop and the
idea is we gave up a knight one a bishop
but we took away this center pawn so we
still have our two center pawns they
only have the one and we want a pawn in
a really good position we're still
making a lot of threats
but the difference is
uh they also have uh knight takes e5
and now this looks like
wait a minute aren't we actually still
losing because they're going to take our
bishop
but we have a really good move queen to
b5 and we pick the knight back up
so this does work out versus had you
played
knight takes here
knight takes c5 we can't actually win
this piece anymore
so again that's the basic of this trap
but i want to spend the next two
focusing on this idea of targeting this
f7 pawn
so again looking at uh
trips uh tricks and uh
traps over here i'm gonna do that with
two really common openings so we already
looked at the carl khan we'll come back
to that in a second this one actually
comes from a scandinavian defense
so that is e4 d5
black immediately striking back in the
center this is a solid beginning move i
actually recommend it to beginners
because
it's very forcing
white only has one good move here and
that's to take the pawn
some people might try knight c3 or other
moves but this is really the only move
that keeps an advantage for white
the problem here is after knight c3
we're developing this piece for free and
now black has to move the queen and
decide where they want it do they want
to put it on a5 d8 but wherever it goes
it seems like it's wasting a move i
think it's still holdable for a beginner
queen to d8
knight to f3 knight to f6 uh bishop to
c4 this is just one possible line in the
scandinavian
um
and there's two moves i want to show one
of them
bishop to g4 here
there's a bit of a problem with this
move
i want to see if anybody can spot it
how should white continue in this
position
kind of continuing with the theme of
finding nice mating ideas early in the
game
what would you play if you had white
here
all right yeah so my c i'm just going to
call you
mick mick here in the chat um
once again 95
really solid idea it's the same kind of
thing right
we're offering the queen but we're
threatening a checkmate and here it's
actually just checkpoint right away
right
um because if they take
you don't even need to move this knight
in because this pawn is blocking the
king
so this is just checkmate the knight is
covering both of these squares and the
bishop is hitting the king so so yeah
already that's a mistake um
so you already can be on the lookout for
those kind of moves if they're playing a
little better right let's say something
like a6
i would still say 95 is a really solid
try right putting a lot of pressure here
now instead of just letting you have
this checkmate let's say our opponent
plays a good move
e6 the move here i would recommend is
queen to e2 because this creates a
really interesting trap
if something like knight to d7 which
looks like a really natural move right
attacking our knight i'm trying to get
it out and take some more space maybe
following it up with like bishop c5 and
black looks like they're going to be
doing okay
again in this position white has a
really strong
tactical idea
any suggestions for white
and continuing with the same thing we've
already looked at
i'll take e6 with the bishop okay so
pawn takes what's your follow up
cooley 29 thank you for the subscription
so the problem here is this looks good
right white's weakened or sorry we've
weakened black's
attack here but the problem is now we
would want to normally follow this up
with like queen h5
we can't because of this knight on f6
um if this knight isn't here then queen
h5 was a deadly threat because we're
either coming in for some kind of mating
idea
or after like g6 we can win this knight
or sorry this rook
but just on its own bishop takes e6 is
not quite good enough there's a bit of a
stronger idea and i think
yeah mick again in the chat you found it
um so knight d5 another suggestion
this one looks really fascinating
i don't think it works but it is quite
interesting the idea being
if like pawn takes there's now some big
problems like here
we're hitting the queen and the king
i wonder if knight takes
bishop takes you're looking at maybe a
similar thing
i don't know that is interesting but
even stronger than that
is uh as someone else said yeah mick
said knight takes f7
so instead of taking here we're going to
take here and we're going to remove
instead of the front line we're going to
move the back line
and now big problem uh the queen and the
rooker hit so the only sensible move to
try and stay in the game is to take
but now the queen and the bishop
activate it together
and this is going to be uh at the end of
the game very soon the only move the
king has is to come out to g6
and after something like h4 maybe
threatening h5
um it's going to be very hard for black
to defend this
would you um show that again of course i
have a hard time sacrificing anything
that's okay because i haven't i haven't
got that in my strategy so i didn't
really quite see that so that's okay so
sacrificing is really scary and i
wouldn't do it
at an early level unless you see the
concrete idea to either win the same
amount of material back or get some
checkmate so here the problem that black
is entered
is they restrict themselves with this
knight
and we have a lot of pieces coming in at
the center
so what we can see is okay if this pawn
is like out of the way we have just a
direct line of access to their king and
our bishop and queen are working
together here
the problem is twofold one are knights
in the way and two
uh these pawns are defending each other
and we can say let's solve both problems
at once
our knight's gonna move out of the way
and remove the guard of uh this center
pawn and with nothing left to take care
of it
it's gonna be pretty easy if something
like queen to e7 right to try and avoid
all this mating nonsense
um probably you can just take the rook
and we're winning by material there
might also be ideas of bishop takes e6
defending and
all of it's really gross for black
but that's kind of the basic idea
uh yeah mickey got a really good point
here knight d7 also a problem because
now this bishop can't defend the pawn
either so they've actually removed this
defender so another good thing to be
aware of
okay let's move to the next one so we're
going to see a really similar trap in
the karo khan
so we saw this earlier
i actually play the two knights against
the karo khan so this is an example of a
game that i've gotten many times we have
these pawns traded here
and the knights are just really nice and
active
and i'm going to show you kind of two
ideas one if they play knight to f6
you can do the same thing as we talked
before and take and then they have to
double their pawn somewhere but i think
even stronger is queen e2
and now there's some really funny moves
uh knight takes e4 is the main move but
if they play something like knight to d7
this is just a fun cute one anyone see
how
white can continue
in this position with a really good idea
yeah someone else in the chat we have uh
slot odds
42 i don't know how to pronounce your
name but knight d6
and this is checkmate
so quickly in right this is not far into
this game we are like one two three
four oh whoops
four
five
oh wait i keep doing the wrong variation
we're we're getting some spoilers here
for you and that's not my goal here it
is knight bd7 move five and uh the sixth
move knight to d6 and this is a
smothered mating idea but the idea is
we've pinned this pawn and the knights
attacking this isn't really the point
it's just kind of a little cute aside i
want to look at
the main move which would be not to
congest yourself with knight to d7 but
to take here
i mean i would take back
and now again putting pressure on f7 is
just such a key idea for those who don't
know
the these are the two weakest pawns on
the board because they're only defended
at the starting position by the king
so they become really good targets for
this reason
so i would play something like uh so
black's probably going to play knight to
d7
to then reroute to f6 wanting to attack
our queen we pull out our bishop to c4
to get a nice attack
and now knight to e5
again the same idea offering up our
queen
you can't take it because of checkmate
um so again e6 the most natural move
trying to block this bishop
and we're going to see something very
similar here i would just move back to
e2
and then again black can get themselves
into a lot of trouble very quickly
if they play the wrong move
something like um
well
yeah something again if obviously if
they just do this you have the same trap
but that would be a little silly
don't know why they would block their
pawn with the knight but we just have a
lot of really good pressure here i mean
it's going to be easy to exploit there
is another way we can see that same
variation though and that's if back in
the beginning here right
if instead of playing uh knight to f6
they play bishop to f5
another way to arrive at a similar trap
i would drop back to g3 trying to trade
and get the bishop
so after the bishop moves back h4 really
aggressive moving towards trapping this
bishop
h6 giving it the escape square
and knight e5 again such a strong
centralized knight
really uh it looks like we're going for
the bishop but we're really targeting
this f7 square
uh bishop drops back
and now queen to h5 making a mate threat
uh if you don't respond i'm just going
to take with checkmate
so g6 is kind of the only move here that
looks good
and there's a few moves that i play here
there's really two i like to play the
move queen to f3
and after this i would go over here and
i'm forking the checkmate and the rook
but
continuing with our theme another really
good move after g6
anyone uh have another idea for white
again happy to sacrifice some material
if we can make a really strong attack
maybe a mating attack
so it's interesting so what's your idea
if i take the queen
yeah so so we do have the yeah we do
have to worry about this right
is uh
is like retreating the queen an option
yeah so that's the move i was looking at
first was this queen to f3 and this is
the move that i like to play this is a
great move
because again we're threatening the same
checkmate and then i like to then
reroute
and make the checkmate threat and attack
their rook
but there is another way you can do it
uh yen
uh ibrahimo
uh yeah you have the move i like bishop
c4
sacking the queen again
right
but we have this same kind of this isn't
quite legal's mate but it's the same
similar idea where we're controlling all
of these squares
um
so obviously they can't take the queen
here so they're going to play something
like e6 let's say and then after queen
to e2 you can see this same pattern
right our queen and our bishop are
working together and our knight is
really threatening a lot of space
and just starting to sacrifice itself so
in this position there's just so many
ways black can go wrong
there's only the moves that really keep
everything tied together so like queen 2
d7 or e7 um but any other move if you
play bishop to g7 if you play knight to
d7 right all of these moves fall victim
to this same
theme
knight takes f7
king takes
queen takes
um
and there's really just nothing you can
do
if you were playing black and you were
in this position
yeah so so exactly so the threat is well
one i i would not want to be in this
position but if i was right it's not
always a choice
um
this is the threat that we have to deal
with so the problem here is unlike the
previous variation where we still had a
bishop accessible to defend now the
bishop's been
pushed aside to h7 so it can't really
play a role here
i would probably play
i would probably play queen two c7 here
um with the idea that i'm defending the
pawn so if you try and like sacrifice
i can take um
like this
um
e7 is another alternative but i don't
like this one as much because it's
blocking our bishop a little bit more
now there's a good chance our bishop
wants to come over here anyway
so that's probably okay but
um just something to consider but i i
think those are really maybe the only
moves i mean i can even double check
yeah queen e7 and queen c7 are the only
two moves that survive
um
all because this thread is just too big
okay uh so let's switch gears a little
bit to another kind of uh opening trap
that's very famous and this one for
those who may have heard of it this is
called the fishing pole so if you've
heard of it be excited it's a fun one
but there's a lot of ways to get this
we're going to start from a simple e4 e5
um just main line stuff right knight f3
knight c6 this is what books have been
written about then we have a roy lopez
or a spanish opening
knight to f6 is the berlin defense and
now castles
this is all main theory there's a lot of
stuff here
knight takes e4 is an idea but it runs
into like rookie one
and you're probably going to win this
pawn back
so there's lots of different ways to
play
but there's a bit of an odd move knight
to g4 we're removing the same piece
twice we're not taking the pawn
um
and we've kind of exposed ourselves
right there's maybe ideas of this knight
moving and the queen attacking so it
looks a little scary and it also looks a
little silly because
after h3
white's basically saying okay what was
your point right you just wasted a move
you have to now move back and i get a
free move
uh but here
black actually has a really solid play
well black has no intention of moving
that knight
so h5
we are fortifying and creating an attack
and
what is the problem here
if white just says okay i'm just going
to take your knight
what's the problem
we're opening up the rook
so after i take i'm threatening the
knight
and the rook is now on this open file
really beautiful file the queen is ready
to come in and i actually don't think
there's a good way to stop checkmate
here uh probably the only way to try is
to sacrifice tonight
anywhere you move the night i'm coming
in
and i don't really know what you do here
maybe something like f3 to try and as
soon as i take this pawn or take the
knight
you can escape but it's actually a
really devious move that black can play
to
guarantee a win here
so instead of taking the knight what
should we do that's even a little better
yeah
this knight has nowhere to go anyway so
we're just going to cut off the escape
square
and now like there's just no move um
anything you play if you're trying to
open up space we're gonna take
and here one more really good find
how do we find a checkmate in this
position
chest dojo live thanks for the raid
welcome
broke out a really fun idea in the
fishing pole here
so yeah it's black to move we obviously
want to play just like queen to h8
but the problem is um
the king has an escape square so what do
we do about that
yeah knight to d4 and somebody in the
chat said it too jelly play kit
um
and now there's just no stopping
checkmate um the pawn and the knight are
working together to cut up the escape
squares
and i don't think there's actually any
legal move that white can play that
stops queen to h8
so this is the fishing pole idea
again if we go back
you don't have to
like allow this to happen
white's best move here is just to play
like d3 or c3 preparing d4
um but if you take you run into serious
problems because even if the knight
stays right even if you try now and open
stuff up and maybe get the bishop and
the queen involved
um
we're going to take the knight so we win
it back
and we still have this threat of queen
to h4 so if you take back with the queen
or with the pawn
queen h4 is a big threat
we also always have the ever-present
threat of knight coming into d4
so again we're just really overwhelming
and hopefully you can see kind of the
common theme is
our we're willing to make some
sacrifices if we can get a lot of
activity and provoke a lot of weaknesses
uh at the king right so before we were
looking at f7
in this case we're looking at a castled
king and kind of this h2 weakness
and there's a really similar way to
exploit this that i'm going to show in a
kind of
pretty combination here in a moment
but i want to pop over to
another kind of
opening middle game sacrifice
checkmating idea
and this one we're going to look at the
white side again
e4 e6 we have a french defense d4 d5
um
knight 2 c3 again nothing too unusual
here
knights to f6 and we're going to push
knight comes back and again this is a
really common uh series of moves in the
french white's taking space black is
fighting back
um bishop b4 is played bishop d3
and castles and i want to say it's here
yeah in this position white has a really
nice plan
of attack so if anyone has ideas how
should white proceed in this variation
it looks really common all these moves
we've taken some space in the center but
black's doing fine right they've
developed their bishop with a pin their
knights ready to
support a c5 pawn push um but there's a
big problem
um what do you mean pinning the back row
i don't know
that you'd set yourself up for being
trapped it's probably in this the point
is you're attacking the bishop bishop's
gonna have to do something and they're
either gonna have to back off which
would be good for us
um if they back off over here we could
probably play like this
um but probably they're just gonna take
and
like this is okay we can maybe push here
now defended by the bishop but
um
i don't see that this is maybe gonna
trap us if anything this might open
white up to continue attacking later on
but there is a stronger move and a few
people in chat have said it this is the
classic greek gift i don't actually know
where it gets its name but the idea is
we're going to sack this bishop
on h7
and it looks problematic but we have a
lot that's ready to jump in even though
it doesn't look like it our knight's
ready to come to g5 our bishop is
supporting
once the knight moves the queen can come
in and maybe we can start a pawn storm
and this is actually quite a strong
attack
so um oh i do know where the name comes
from that's right the trojan horror
story right where uh troy the greeks
faked giving like this wooden horse it's
all a legend or a myth or whatever but
the point is the greeks were hiding
inside so we're giving this gift this
beautiful bishop and if black takes it
well i'll tell you if black doesn't take
it it doesn't really matter um because
now we just have a free pawn we can drop
back and we're gonna do the same thing
but it's just worse
so you really have to take it and the
problem is here knight to g5
our queen and our bishop are activated
the pawn's coming forward
you can't take the knight because the
bishop defends
so the king has a few moves here
the king can go to any of these four
squares
somebody pick one which one do you want
to see uh how to stop
we'll take a look at all of them but
is there a game
yeah g8 um looks pretty sensible uh it's
probably the hardest one to stop maybe
besides like g6
um but still the idea is very simple
we have a huge threat here on h7 so how
do we continue that threat
yeah
um and there's not a lot to do again you
can sack the queen whenever you want i'm
happy with that um if you try and make
space
like rook to e8 with the idea that now
okay our king's gonna try and run away
what happened last time when the king
tried to make an escape square how did
we stop it
would be right isn't that right uh well
specifically we played the knight to d4
but just the general idea is we cut off
the escape square right yeah we could
call check here and that's like okay
but we actually want to do more we want
to get a checkmate so what's the best
way to continue here
yeah so we take here first and this
removes our uh
removes the escape the king now comes
back
and then from here
probably just come back
and
check the difference is without that
pawn there
check
checkmate
there's nothing to save you
in this position our pawn is cutting off
all the escapes and again we took this
one had we not done that right had we
gone here first
then now this is still good but
like why are we letting our opponent
play on you know
um so you want to be kind of aware of
those ideas and how to uh stop them so
king to g8
um probably the easiest one to beat is
king to h8
right because it's the same idea but
this is check now so you only have one
move
other ones that are maybe a little
more uh dubious
if king comes to h6
how can we win this game
uh where
between i know
yeah i wanted i wanted you to get to it
i wanted you to get there you got to
believe in yourself yeah
yeah alex or m9 excellent yeah it's a
discovery right so it it is uh defended
by the rook but that doesn't matter
because our bishop is calling check too
so again double check such a powerful
tool
because it forces the king to move and
wherever the king goes we're taking the
queen
um
if the king comes here to g6
what do you think we ought to do now
because like yeah the king's way up in
the middle but it doesn't matter if
we're not
if we're not actually getting it
yeah queen g4 i think that's uh
a good idea
i i definitely like the look of this and
it's possible there's a way to escape uh
maybe like f5 and it gets a little weird
but we're probably still fine and we're
probably winning the queen
um another way to do it is just h4
and very simple point we're going to h5
um there's not really anything you can
do to stop it
and once you go back we're also winning
the queen
but that i think queen g6 probably is
good enough um
or sorry queen of g4
uh yeah it's gonna be good enough um
no problems for us there okay so we
looked at the fishing pole in the greek
gift i want to show one example of a
greek gift from uh one of my games
so again this thing it's not just like
these
cool little ideas that happen it's like
yo this happens in actual games you play
it's not always the same position
so we had a french so again same kind of
idea
a little different right the knight came
forward instead of back there's a bishop
here my night's here so stuff changes
um
but we just had a normal solid opening
game um
but the problem was
i started with h4 and after pawn takes
pawn
uh i should have right away played the
greek gifts i missed it for a move
knight came to b4 and then i found it
it's the same idea here but now we're
actually doing the best of both worlds
because now
after king takes wait a minute we have a
bishop and a queen here
right so now they can take but what's
the problem
it's the fishing pole right we put them
both together if they take
we activate our rook
so you can combine these themes
um and if you understand kind of the
pattern like let's say king to g6
then we can find the right solution
if they don't take right if they just go
back to g8 then it's what we look at
we're looking at before with um
the greek gift
and all the same threats are there and
you gotta choose okay are you gonna try
and stop it
well we know this one what's the
continuation here
how does white win if they uh try and
make an escape square over here
yep we take the pawn we cut off the
escape
and goes back
now what
check
check
check
and uh this actually just is checkmate
because the knight's covering it and
their bishop is stopping them from
escaping so we know that one right um
and if they don't if they take the the
knight
well then we just reactivate the the
fishing pole right so it's a really
beautiful thing to be aware of all of
these themes and how they play together
um because that's what i figured out in
this game i saw the best of a greek gift
in it and there's just no way to stop
any of our ideas
so i want to show
i think we have time for two more quick
games
uh and these are both master games these
are not mine but i want to show there's
just some really beautiful ideas this
one took place in 1894 between carl
schlechter and siegfried wolfe also in
vienna
in this game again same thing we have a
french
and so hopefully you'll start to
recognize some of these themes
so bishop comes out and we trade so
that's a little different right all of
these variations
are variations on a theme if we
recognize the idea that if you're
playing now in this kind of structure
maybe you recognize okay yeah bishop d3
maybe i'm thinking about bishop h7 when
i can do that
um bishop d7
h4
write the same thing i was doing
f6
and now
right uh wolf here is actually aware of
the problem he plays f6
because he doesn't want this knight
jumping in
because he knows that yeah if you take
the bishop and then knight jumps in
there's going to be a big problem
so
so what do we do here
white to move
and it seems like they know our threats
right we've built on this but now
there's a queen of bishop and upon all
stopping the knight
what should we do
okay we have one suggestion bishop takes
h7
any other suggestions
let's do a quick look at that so bishop
takes h7 looks like it makes a lot of
sense um
because king takes and we have the same
knight g5 fishing pole idea right
they're going to take and then we're
going to activate
um here
obviously if they play like bad moves
like king h8 yeah we know how to win
this we've done it before
um
but there actually is a bit of a problem
because after king g6
it's really unclear
exactly how white wins this game
uh we can get close
he takes f6 maybe g takes
uh check
but f5 and
like black is definitely not in a
comfortable position
maybe there's eventually ideas of h5 but
white's had to sacrifice a lot right we
don't have our bishop here anymore we
don't have our bishop here anymore um
so maybe we can hold maybe we can get a
drop but this is a little scary
so bishop takes 87 is a cool idea but it
doesn't quite work
and someone else again uh obrahim here
in this chat did find the right move
remarkably in this position despite
everything black has attempted
the queen the bishop and the pawn all of
it lined up to stop us from playing
knight to g5 carl selector says i don't
care i'm playing this anyway you cannot
stop my knight
and now there's just a huge problem
um
in the game pawn takes knight because
what else
now bishop takes h7
king takes h7
h takes g5
and uh the difference is we've already
gotten this work open right we didn't
leave them the opportunity
king goes back to g8 and in this
position there's actually only one way
to move and to win
so see if you can find the best move i
think every other move is drawing at
best
so push the pawn up looks uh really good
but i think there's a bit of a problem
because i want to say uh i think rook f5
and the king can walk away and there's
not really any way to get in
maybe not because if rick have yeah work
out five and the problem is yeah the
king can walk away and more importantly
they're stopping our queen
so this is the problem
g6 looks really good
but it's not quite good enough
what about the
just kind of hanging out
our knight is hanging out the problem is
as much as we would love to like get
this piece more involved it's just too
far
um
and our problem is we've sacked some
pieces so the thing we're needing to
keep on is the momentum so we don't have
quite enough time to route the night
over
okay sack in the rook and that's also
been uh recommended by a few people in
the chat so let's take a look at that
rook h8
and again this looks kind of silly
but the problem is now
is if black takes
then they activate our queen
and we come here with check so there's
no time
king to g8 now g6 comes in and the king
has no escape
rook.5 doesn't work anymore
because of check and checkmate
okay so what about rook h8 what if they
play
king f7
now what do we do
okay so it's still checked but it's on
the diagonal
um i think the only move here g6
how do we finish this
queen f7 check okay again only move
king here to e8
yeah
and the problem is it doesn't look like
checkmate at first because like wait the
work's gonna block
but it's pinned
so this is checkmate a really beautiful
attack again combining a lot of these
themes together
and i want to show one more we have a
couple minutes left
this is
so this is uh carl schlechter versus
siegfried wolff on vienna in 1894.
really really classic game but again the
main ideas
are
looking at our piece placement seeing
okay yeah knight g5 again it looks like
a crazy move but if we realize
that our bishop is coming our rook is
going to get activated our queen's
coming in uh we can calculate that out
and actually find the best attack so
it's about peace placement it's about
activity
um
and just recognizing some of these
patterns right this this pattern has
come up a lot
this last one here is a really famous
game i believe it's referred to
as fatal attraction which i think for
a valentine's themed lesson is pretty
perfect
the fatal attraction here this takes
place between edward lasker and george
thomas in 1912 and this happened in
london and if you haven't seen it oh
you're in for a treat
d4 e6 knight to f3
f5 really weird opening um do not see
this every day
white is sorry black is automatically
exposing their king but with the knight
on f3
it's maybe unclear um
like there's not any obvious threats
right our pawn is still on e2 our
knights on f3 our queen's not going to
be able to come in very soon so this is
actually like it's not good but black
isn't
losing
so we continue with some main moves
knight to c3 knight to f6
uh bishop pinning the knight and
unpinning and then there's a trade
and now e4 you know white has recognized
you've pushed this pawn so i do want to
get my piece out and i'm going to take
up some space in the center to do so
pawn takes pawn knight takes
b6 so black is probably indicating they
want their bishop to come on this nice
long diagonal
knight comes to e5 we've seen this
before right always be afraid of the
knight on e5 it's attacking a lot of
squares
and there's actually an immediate threat
here black tasseled but let's say
instead they continued with their plan
and played bishop to b7
how does white continue from here and
get an advantage
yeah james clark in the chat is
suggesting queen h5
and this is the point yeah uh we've
gotten rid of these two pieces that were
in our way
and now black has no good move right if
you just move the king oh well that's
that's rough
uh same thing obviously here it's still
checkmate so the only move is to block
with the pawn and uh now what
yes
it takes g6 james you had it again um
and the problem is if pawn takes
we win the rook
we don't win the rook hold on we take
the bishop first
we take the pawn here sorry because yeah
the bishop defends
looks good though
but yeah we're going to take here and
then we're going to win the bishop
most likely if they play here
it's gonna be a little weird but i still
think
you know white's doing just fine
okay back to our game so castles to
avoid all of those shenanigans
bishop to d3 bishop to b7
and again queen to h5 now
and black played the move queen to e7
uh and in this position again this is
maybe a little harder to find but
continuing with our theme of opening
and middle game checkmating ideas
white pieces are all primed for a
beautiful attack right we have these two
beautiful knights covering so much space
here in the center our queen is aimed at
the king our bishop is maybe ready for
some kind of discovery
um
and the king is ready to castle either
way if that's necessary at any point
so
again kind of hard to find here but what
moves do you think we should play i have
someone saying knight takes f6 someone
saying queen takes h7
what moves should we look at here to
find an advantage
uh knight g5 okay another move
um knight to g5
is interesting
right because you can't take it we're
threatening mate with uh
the queen and bishop because we have our
night guarding this square
so i do like this move
i think maybe the only problem i can see
is we're not obliged to take right black
doesn't have to
so maybe
could you use the upper knight
sacrifices
well i'll say this yeah hope is a
beautiful thing and it's it's important
to have
in chess
the times i hope are when i'm losing and
i like there's nothing else i can do i
hope someone makes a mistake but in this
case we actually can find a win so we
don't need to hope we just need to think
um
knight to g5 maybe there's ideas of like
h6
and it's gonna get complicated because
there's forks
um but there's also taking this piece
and it's gonna be a little weird
the crazy good move that a few people
are suggesting now
again hard to see but just for the
thematic continuation as queen takes h7
and we're sacrificing our queen and
there's only one move
king takes
from here
how should we continue
we've given up our queen but our pieces
are really primed for some beautiful
attacks to happen
so what do you think
so we definitely want a discovery i
agree
so g5 is still interesting but there's
actually a little better i want to get
rid of this piece
and we're going to do the same thing
we're just taking a piece away so yeah
double check and now we have two moves
if you go back here how do you finish
this
knight g6 and all of the squares are
taken
so you can't go back king up to h6 all
right how about now
well how do we continue our attack
we have a lot of squares restricted
so we want to keep pushing the king away
what if we use the knight to put the key
where do you want to put it
yeah so we have two nuts that can go
there which one do you want to use
yeah master of ceremony this is a really
famous game so you probably have seen it
before
uh whoever said someone in the chat name
master of ceremony
um
so i would uh i think this one's a
little better
the reason being is this knight is still
controlling some space that we want to
keep locked down
so after knight from e
the king has one move
how do we keep the pressure on
where's another attacking move
h4 check once again king has one move
right our knight
we're guarding all the space the bishop
he has one move f4
how about now
we gotta keep up the pressure
g3 check i love it check train the king
started all the way back here and we've
walked him all the way up all the way up
he's got one move again
there's a few ways to finish this game
but there's one really spectacular way
so how where can we continue this
attacking
uh-huh where
oh right in front of the king yep okay
bishop g2 check king has one move
and it's checkmate in two
h2 king has one move
in this position you get one of the
coolest checkmates in the game
queenside castle checkmate
we got the king all the way from
g7
walking all the way down
what's the name so this is called fatal
attraction it was edward lasker versus
george thomas super famous game
incredibly beautiful mate
alternatively you can also just play
king to d2 and this is also made um
really fun game and the point isn't like
obviously this is beginner breakdown i'm
not asking you to calculate perfectly
all these variations but all of these
had some really common themes we're
focusing on hitting the king
getting our pieces active and aimed and
hopefully that if you encounter some of
these in your own games whether it be
the greek gift or the fishing pole
or just some of those more common
targeting f7 traps maybe sacking a
knight or a bishop
hopefully you'll be able to see some of
those and use some of those in your game
so again thank you all for joining me
both in person and in the chat i've been
alex and please stick around because up
next we have uh legends in st louis with
ilya nizhnik thanks so much